salut à tous ici pêcheurs de trésors
alors aujourd'hui on est avec jp pêche
aveuglément scotty five et alex pour une
grosse pêche sous un pont dans l'hérault
donc c'est le fleuve hérault donc ici ça
va être très compliqué desrochers tout
mais on est motivé comme jamais alors
c'est parti et les bénévoles en bateau
sont arrivées pour nous aider à
décoincer les aimants malheureusement
ils sont trompés de chemin on y allait
rattraper après
avoir évincé vite parce que ce quotidien
m 2 heures à préparer un patois l'ag du
lou reed à un
quart d'heure de voiture
c'est pas mignon t'as pas sympa
et la regarder ce qu'on voyait du bord
une pelle à l'appel et ça c'est un
antivol de boules de voiture
sympa
donc ça commence bien
alors ils ont
deux heures qu'on va être une tenue de
plongée
avec l'image
j'ai des choses
j'ai l'accord de les mains habiles et la
sai a gelé nos hommes et c'est un 360
est sûre ce n'est pas un midi ou quoi ah
non non c'est un plateau
petit aimant
moi c'est lui je
n'ai en rien il y en a peut-être
d'autres bombes à super un petit moment
il a dû bien galéré et avec ça sert à
rien de rester assise au
wild après
quoi
d'un cheval cadenas
d'un
autre côté tu vas dans l'eau tu sors le
morceau de voitures tout seul allez
ouais
belle bête
ah ouais c'est un tableau de bord on
s'est rapprochés pas bien
ouais nickel
des clés de voiture à son vieil
way la caisse
bien jouer sa
pratique
oh
un cric
bien joué en plongée
aux
eaux une demie fourche
et une mâchoire de fin sympa
moi
aussi ancien ça ouais
et ça ça a l'air d'être un vieil outil
ou quelque chose comme ça avec l'aps
ouais c'est une poignée de la poignée
n'est pas en faire alors les tons
et bien
pas rafraîchi
à saillé
a bien sauvé
je vais aller voir
oui regardeur après regarde à temps
plein
c'est une caisse ainsi quand il porte de
coffre fort porte de temps trop fort
mais faute rôle coffre ans maintenant
oh eun sun
15h10 leveaux plus
coincé dans le monde
on va travailler
à yabuli bout d'un mois on va trier le
gagner une guerre voyez mastoc allez
c'est parti
et derrière ça du tout oui il ya du
béton
peut-être sur le fait basculer la phase
i du trailer
[Musique]
bon du coup fait un lingot par personne
les gars ça vous va bien il veut plus
venir en sarthe la prixtel mon cher que
voter quotas ce spot il est mieux ça va
bien là bas
[Musique]
temmar
mais d'où son mari
manu rivière
[Musique]
voir
f
1 2 3
voilà la lave inverse elle lâche fait
tourner
ouais bien jouer dans mon talent et
oligo
le monde
c'est un monstre tout à fait sonner
comme ça ou pas dans le nord webb à des
courses et régulé ouais mais c'est comme
ça au sirop
auteur à oui oui on va bien joué les
gars n'étaient pas simples
balles et 11 4 dans les gares
ya beaucoup de vase pareillement
vide et plein de vides
et pleins ou vides bah si déjà on arrive
déjà à être vidé serrières sera moins
lourd
quand on perd des
points semble
attention riquet ça vole pas
un monceau de coffre
tiens 250 euros la tonne
c'est beau temps as un pas sûr non plus
que la série allait ou non
non je pense pas
assez de la fontaine à ce dont une
partie du corps toulouse
une carte de visite
non c'est quand de tels accords nous
taperons offre d'hôtels à l'hôtel
ça va mais attend la gueule
dans les yeux
des trous
et là c'est à toulouse toulouse deux
noms qui
bah moi je les vois deux heures de
travail badénois francfort ouest et
risque un peu car il était un peu tendu
dans le méga
watts un vrai régal désolé
moi ça fait ça allait c'est la branche
gros comme proctor avec la team p chef
clément et spotify est des fois quand
elle les avait amenés n'importe où il y
avait rien du tout
c'est méchant il y avait des pêcheurs où
il y avait des pêcheurs qui sont venus
avec eux scotty's on en fait oui voilà
mon pas dire qu à merveille ma porte je
suis pas d'accord
on n'a pas eu de chance
ça fait le banc de boules c'est bon à
oui bon le retour nous quoi tu la gagnes
tu me choisir pour longtemps voilà
c'est quoi tes de delko
cette époque
c'est bizarre ce truc elle est restée
bien sûr une piscine prévue alors
voilà
oh bien joué ouais le pneu
ou
facile à
huawei
morceau voiture
allait
les papiers
casque est ce que ce bordel
jusque juste que c'est énorme c'est un
moteur et nous
savons qu'il est là fort s'est offert un
jour
[Applaudissements]
oh oh
oh
allez
bon ben voilà on évacue les déchets
après cette grosse journée beau temps a
passé quoi cette journée c'était cool
pour nous c'est pas encore l'été mais
c'est déjà l'été quoi on est déjà à
l'eau tranquille ici
et dans les zones où le guidon dessous
vous galérez là les
gallois mais
et pour jpa les halles yalla vas aller
rés
allez
retrouver lola
il arrive donc
au une batterie assez original
voilà ça fait là les sauces ou satin les
anges et les ferrailleurs oui c'est la
tête la première dans l'eau presque
et c'est une bonne dépollution également
[Musique]
1,1 pour le revendre en faire ailleurs
s'il a fallu faire à l'esbrouffe
clairement à
waimes aime ça ah ouais chez nous chez
nous le verrions merde il est obligé
d'écouter l'heure c'est fabrice que vous
avez dit qu'ils soient
pas peut-être on va essayer de se
découper un
trio tan dis non c'est clair mais bon
j'aurais dû garder un peu de dynamique
sonore
t'avais dit jp qu'on a péché une
vingtaine de bâtons de dynamite ont la
vache
équipé d'un aimant j'ai passé par maison
de la détection avec les meilleurs
éléments du marché les aimants barbarian
de chez magnetar fin bon ben voilà avec
ça pas besoin d'en dire plus je pense
que tout est déjà sur la photo bon ben
voilà le bilan de la pêche de la journée
avec toutes les teams qui était présente
il ya les liens dorchen en descriptions
alors des voix
lee des morceaux de voiture les normes
trop fort embêtant des caisses qui était
vide malheureusement et là la prochaine
fois il faut qu'on revienne ki moon est
chaud les gars pour trouver le coffre
qui allait avec cette porte outils
motivés pendant le congé et non mais
c'est énorme et sec donc ils rentrent
dans la combinaison c'est bon